there was a Workaholics movie in the
cards oh yeah uh I'm guessing Paramount
plus because it's a Viacom yeah Comedy
Central connection yeah and um
it was green lit all ready to go people
hired and like you know schedule on and
then they it just got shut down at the
last minute
yeah like literally wrote the script uh
we were ready to go we had the cast back
and all scheduled and everything uh we
rented stages and then when they came
back from like uh
in the into the new year like that first
week they were like we've got a whole
new Global agenda right which sounds
dark uh and maybe it is but they've got
a global agenda where basically like
the amount they were going to spend
making our movie our
um intellectual property just wasn't
worth that to them because they were
worried that it wasn't gonna appeal to
International markets right they thought
it was going to be uh like the only
really hit in America and they needed
two Niche two Niche and look
I get it I get it but like
uh tell us that a little sooner sure
tell us that a little sooner but also
like
I'm I'm I'm I'm I feel bad for those
guys over there because Paramount plus
is imploding and when we were working
yeah yeah yeah wow I I um
here comes a can of worms but uh the um
our jackass forever yeah the last
Jackass movie just went to Paramount
plus yeah and and it went to Paramount
plus
um like without any form of of a video
on demand uh window in advance right and
it went to Paramount Plus without any uh
establishing the market value by by uh
bringing it to other streamers it just
they didn't offer it anywhere else they
just sold it to themselves and uh and
there was speculation that
that that was not legal you know I know
I don't doubt it I mean that's the whole
thing this is why we're striking because
everything's changing so quick like the
rules are being made up as they go
OnePlus didn't exist when we negotiated
our contract exactly and then all of a
sudden here it is oh really I didn't
know that you're gonna get paid if it
went to Netflix but it didn't it went to
Paramount right because Viacom the the
the argument was like that that it's not
fair
had they
they taken it to Netflix and gotten an
offer taken it to you know like HBO Max
like whatever and then then they would
have established a market value for it
they would have understood what it's
worth but because they did not do that
they just sold it to themselves
presumably they didn't like uh rip
themselves off you know they they're
notorious for this and they never they
never Syndicate shows for the most part
except for South Park which has like a
different deal uh they like they don't
like to Syndicate which is what
television the whole thing is based on
like you Syndicate so you can make more
money and make more episodes and
subsidize by the way welcome to
Hollywood minute
um [__] and it's just strange because
like uh it feels like they're just in
quicksand man like people are getting
laid off the people we were in contact
with as we were developing it we'd be
like Hey where's Greg they're like
Greg is someone we don't speak about
anymore like people are just like
disappearing consolidating and you're
like yikes from my perspective yeah
they've done you dirty yeah they've done
you dirty on the Workaholics movie and I
know that you guys were uh kind of
putting it out into the ether that what
you wrote is awesome yeah and that like
that you're amiable open-minded to
another entity but so here's the thing
is that they go hey by the way you guys
have I think it was two or three weeks
to find a proper Suitor for this because
if we couldn't do that they needed they
did pay us it was a payer play so we got
paid uh uh because you know they held us
off the market kind of thing and I did
write a script but so they said you got
three weeks because if you guys don't
find somebody before that we're gonna
write it off we're gonna we're gonna use
everything else to write off for taxes
like the National Enquirer catch and
kill dude it's [__] crazy and I go
yeah man hey I'm glad someone's there
crunching the numbers so that uh you
guys are are making ends meet but like
what the [__] is happening presumably
those three weeks elapsed those are over
those are gone they they did the catch
and kill and by the way the whole thing
is like if you're Netflix there were
people who were interested but they
would have to
buy they'd have to pay for the movie and
then at some point it would go back to
Paramount plus and no one's going to do
that right we're in the forever business
now so they would do a licensing deal
with Paramount essentially yeah yeah and
so what what is that two years three
years
against Infinity years you know what I
mean like
I mean what's next for these
conglomerates I know they start buying
they don't know they don't know they
have no idea if they had an idea uh [__]
wouldn't be so wild right now and if you
go to whoop.com that's
w-h-o-o-p you can get yourself started
with the whoop band 4.0 comes with a
waterproof charger that slides on top
and boom you're Off to the Races and if
you use the promo code Stevo at checkout
then you get 10 off your order yeah
yeah dude